I like being in relationships I like
being in love yeah
well Aaron Carter is probably a loving
at life right now because the 30 year
old just revealed on Instagram that he's
got a new girlfriend
on Monday the singer posted this sweet
photo of his leading lady Lena
Valentina cuddling with an adorable pup
along with the caption I finally found
my love no one has understood me and
shown the love this woman has for me at
verse Aaron went on to promise Lena a
future family and everlasting respect
writing you have my heart for the rest
of my life our relationship is new but
we will grow old together and have our
family you've shown me you're the woman
I've always dreamed of
[Music]
Valentina a russian-born artist who's
currently residing in LA was the first
to break the news of their relationship
on a social media earlier this month she
instagrammed these adorable pics of the
couple with the caption my love what
happened and on Sunday she took two
instant orys with more video of the
adorable pup from Aaron's pic which
based on her caption appears to be the
new couples joint her child
[Music]
Carter was previously linked to Madison
Parker but the duo split last summer
[Music]
on Valentine's Day he opened up to et
about their breakup do you miss the ex I
might miss the idea of the relationship
but at the same time there were certain
things like I don't like about it like I
got it was to codependence codependent
relationship what ultimately caused that
breakup because you guys seemed very
much in love yeah it was little things
like little dumb nagging types
relationship stuff that it wasn't
anything that was like too detrimental
or anything but it was just the course
of their relationship I think it just
took its toll
so any chance of a reconciliation I
don't think so yeah Aaron also dropped
this bombshell about his past romantic
relationships I really know I think I
might have been like in lust and
codependent and all those things but not
really truly in love and revealed what
he was looking for next what type of
love are you looking for next that's a
good question
committed patient real no just those
kind of dumb little things we all
deserve to be loved you know yeah truly
genuinely loved for the right reasons
and not for the wrong reason so
[Music]
[Applause]